hey I'm Kumar Mac I'm a student
ambassador from Georgetown University
and I'll be giving a talk on how to win
hyperlocal elections and more using
Mathematica today my talk is on using
Mathematica and using data storage tools
to catalyze your team to better enable
you to win hyper local elections or more
generally just promote a message in a
hyperlocal setting this is kind of the
flow of the presentation I'll go through
four different kind of big-picture
topics first of all I'll talk about the
goals of the strategy used in this
application so basically laying out why
why these strategies are helpful and
when they come up I'll talk about how to
create and clean a master list of
prospects that you can reach out to that
you can use as kind of your your base
for lack of better words how to find
those lists how to procure those
listened and how to make them most
useful for the purpose of delegating to
a team I also talked about ways to
visualize your progress using
Mathematica it's a great way to motivate
your team and it's also a great way for
you to keep track of how well you're
doing for each segment of your prospects
because we'll talk about how to
categorize your prospects and then we'll
kind of wrap up with what I hope to be
kind of an open-ended conversation about
alternative use cases and topics for
further exploration using these
strategies for hyperlocal
settings okay let's dive in so basically
the goals of our strategy are to use
Mathematica to organically make our
message go viral through word of mouth
one another goal is to optimize our
outreach efforts by ensuring that we are
approaching like each of our prospects
in a logical order and that each
prospect is approached by a person who's
most likely to persuade him or her and
that's a very important step because
there's basic human psychology that
shows that people are more likely to
perform a certain action or do something
in your fave
if they're being asked by a close friend
so we'll talk about ways to delegate
amongst your team and we also are
optimizing our outreach efforts by
keeping track of our progress and
storing that data last but not least
another key important goal of our
strategy and why these methods help your
message go viral is because at each
point of the strategy you're encouraging
the people you are communicating with to
persuade other people so it's an
organically useful strategy and the use
case that I used was back at my
University where I was very involved in
our Student Association and so I had a
team
I had a core team and I'll explain what
I mean by core team of five people and
so we use these strategies to basically
segment up our Facebook friends we we
ended up using Facebook to put together
our list of prospects but this is my use
case and this is a very hyper local
setting because there are only six
thousand students at Georgetown but it's
still a pretty sizeable population and
it's difficult to keep track of if
you're just using pen and paper and so
that's where tools like Mathematica are
extremely helpful so I want to start the
demo by just talking about what it looks
like to create and clean a master list
of prospects and so as I mentioned this
strategy takes place when you're trying
to spread a message and so our H member
of my core team I encourage them to
download their list of Facebook friends
and that's that's what we used and we
are collecting these lists and
ultimately we're going to aggregate them
and so for example you can see like
these are these and I also named them in
a pretty natural way I just named them
the person whose friends list it is and
then you can see like you know I have
hundreds of Facebook friends and you can
just scroll through and see you know
what they look like and I also
categorized them alphabetically just to
make the data display easier to read and
so you do that for each member of your
core team so as I mentioned I had there
are five of us and so Xavier did it as
well as you can
see there are a few areas of overlap
between my friends lists and Javier's
friends lists and that's going to be
extremely important and we'll come back
to how to make or how to take advantage
of that fact and so also my
vice-presidential candidate was named
Jessica so we obviously used her list as
well we had a campaign manager named
Mara and we had a communications
director named Cheryl and so as you can
see the goal is to put together you're
as big of a list as possible to begin
with and so you can use Facebook you can
use Twitter you can if it's in even more
local setting you can literally write
them out it's really depends on the use
case but the important thing is that you
complete this first step and get
together all of the prospects that your
core team covers and then the next step
what you do is you want to combine them
to make a master list of prospects and
so there's a couple different ways to do
it because what you want to do is you
you have to ensure that all of these
prospects are in your target demographic
and so based on the use case that could
mean they're of a certain age or they
live in a certain zip code or they fit
some other characteristic in our case we
had to make sure that everyone in our
list was a student at Georgetown who was
eligible to vote and so as you're
thinking about how these strategies can
apply to your day to day life that's an
important step because it can
potentially be an arduous task but it's
extremely important so this is kind of
at the second step as I mentioned all
you do is you aggregate these these
friends lists and as you can see there
are several there are several areas
where there's overlap right so like you
know if you look at a cost or if you
look at Erin there are duplicates
because more than one person from our
core team had this person in their
friends list and so this list right here
has the occurrences from all of the
lists and this is in this final step for
creating and cleaning your master list
of prospects is the most important step
number three where you have to remove
the duplicates remove the repetitions
and
sort the prospects into five tiers and
the reason we have five tiers is because
as I mentioned I had five team members
and you you basically you count the
number of times that each prospect
appears in the set of five lists and for
the prospects who appear in all five
lists you put them in the top tier and
these are the people that you want to
reach out to first because as I
mentioned you want to set up a logical
order to attack this list and to spread
your message and also try to recruit
people to join your movement and to join
the initiative and so this this as I
named it clean master list because it
has these divisions and it has kind of a
starting point for you and your team to
split up the work okay so as I mentioned
once you have the clean master list and
once you have kind of a breakdown based
on the tier structure you want to use
this clean master list to divide the
outreach among your core staff and then
keep track of the results by tier so for
example as I mentioned there were five
of us in our group and we just had to
take a look at the the what is it
two hundred there are 281 prospects in
our first tier and so we split that list
up among the group of us and we decided
you know who would be most likely to
convince a person in that top tier to
join our campaign and you can do that
for the entirety of your first tier or
you can choose a segment but the most
important thing is that what what you
should get from these strategies is that
it doesn't make sense for you to be
reaching out to someone who is only
friends with two members of your core
team if you haven't gone through the
people who are most engaged with your
core team and you also as you as you're
communicating with the people on this
master list you want to have your core
team keep track of the progress and so
we divided it up among kind of three
different possibilities the person that
we reached out to either said yes they
said no or they said maybe and they'll
need a follow-up late
and so this is kind of what it looked
like at the very end and so you know out
of the 1,400 people that were in our
clean master list we were able to keep
track of you know which of these people
said yes and which of these people
ultimately could then go and help us
attack the second tier of prospects and
then so on and so forth up to the third
tier and when combined with your basic
social media strategies that you're
doing just kind of to the general public
to boost your names like we had a
website we had you know obviously flyers
we did events this kind of word-of-mouth
and direct marketing strategy was a
great compliment because people they
hear your message and passing if you're
promoting it but when they're when they
get that face-to-face or when they get
that direct either email Direct Facebook
message direct text message whatever it
may be when they get that direct
engagement they're dramatically more
likely to join your cause and it's
particularly if you can identify who's
the best person from your core team to
make that outreach you'll boost your
results dramatically and so I also kind
of want to show what it looks like to
use Mathematica to display the results
and there are some interesting findings
that I'll try my best to explain kind of
how they came about but as I mentioned
there were 281 people in our first here
who were friends with all five members
and we were able to show what the
breakdown was among who said yes who
said maybe who said no and you know for
the first year you as you can imagine
there's a very high percentage of people
who ultimately said yes and who
ultimately voted for myself and Jessica
and then as you keep going by tier you
can see the percentage of people who say
yes it'll decrease until we get to the
very end and it'll kind of fluctuate
also just kind of a logistical note
there are going to be people who don't
respond to your outreach at all and who
just don't really wanna hear what you're
saying and so everyone in the clean
master list they automatically get a an
indication of no and if they don't
respond
they kind of keep that indication so
that's important bookkeeping strategy as
well if someone is it is not receptive
then you want to keep an account of that
appropriately so I'll keep keep moving
right along so for the thirds here there
were a resounding number of knows a few
yeses but the group the the size of
these tears are also getting smaller
which you can notice because that's part
of why the the talk is framed is like
hyperlocal settings because in a
university there aren't gonna be that
many people who I'm friends with that
four of my close friends aren't so
that's that's the explanation as to why
the size of the tears decreases for the
fourth and the fifth year but as you can
also imagine there are a few people who
are for lack of better words randomly
friends with with a given person so they
may have been a member of their freshmen
floor or they may have met in a class
and that person was as we found in like
the fourth tier there are a lot of
people who were actually pretty open to
the idea even though they didn't know
much about myself or know much about a
member of our team so it really just
fluctuates but the general strategy is
that you want to take a logical and
strategic approach to how you reach out
to people so I'm going to now transition
to the part of my talk where I kind of
explore what the strategies would look
like for alternative use cases and what
the strategies can also how they can be
expanded upon in the future so as I
mentioned we were in a student
government election but these strategies
can also be extremely these strategies
could also be extremely helpful for like
a small municipal election you know if
someone is running for county clerk or
running for a judge position whatever it
may be the that person especially
because they have a much bigger budget
than than we had they can put together a
list of their close friends and they can
put together a
kind of more robust spreadsheet and have
people kind of organized by their
neighborhood organized by the coldest I
organized by their Neighborhood
Association membership whatever it may
be and conduct this kind of
word-of-mouth viral marketing in the
same way there's also a kind of a little
bit more about myself I'm very
interesting entrepreneurship and
something that founders always encounter
is a lack of exposure with their minimal
viable products but by using these
strategies you can kind of segment your
prospects and reach out to members who
are members of your community that will
be willing to try your product and then
while they're at it you can tell them
you know a specific group of
acquaintances that they know as well who
they can refer the product to as well
last but not least it could also be
extremely helpful for spreading a
petition and that this that kind of
process is becoming much easier through
the use of internet than it was in the
past something else I want to touch on
other topics for exploration that I
think could add to the richness and the
impact of these strategies would be kind
of weighting the weighting each team
member differently when you're
segmenting the members into tiers so for
example I was the presidential candidate
for my campaign Jessica as I mentioned
was the vice presidential candidate it
would have been kind of fascinating to
see if we could have kind of pref
preferred members of our prospect list
who were friends with myself and Jessica
weighing that heavier than if they were
friends with Sheryl Xavier or Mara and I
think there could be some interesting
kind of data analysis to show kind of
the the the adoption rate or the the
rate at which a member says yes to vote
for us given their their being friends
with myself or Jessica so I think that
would be another interesting kind of
topic to explore last but not least I
think it would also be interesting to to
see what this would look like to do the
the data storage using Wolfram cloud so
for example with us we just we
communicated directly with the people we
reach out to and then
kind of stored the results via Excel and
then just kind of uploaded them to
Mathematica at the end but I think it
could be interesting you know further
when you all you see strategies for your
own use cases you could set up kind of a
Wolfram cloud portal and allow your core
team members and other people you get to
join your movement to log the results
that way yeah I think and also I guess
that's kind of all I have if there are
other use cases that you all have
questions about or if you have questions
about kind of the strategies that we
took for our campaign now it's time
[Applause]